[Musique]
ici le tadjik n'est pas seulement un
immigré c'est aussi une insulte espèce
de tadjik je vous laisse imaginer ce
qu'il ya derrière ici les tadjik ils
sont cantonnés aux basses besognes comme
le déneigement par exemple et les
autorités sanitaires hésitent à leur
donner des permis de travail car selon
une propagande bien installé le tadjik
et soit tuberculeux soient séropositifs
faites votre choix bien vous allez voir
même stigmatiser même moqué le tadjik
sourit à la vie car il est déjà content
d'avoir quitté son pays d'asie centrale
où certes il n'ya plus grand-chose à
faire tête de turc non j'aime mieux être
de tadjiks et c'est un sujet de pierrick
morin
petit matin sur la place rouge vestiges
glacée d'un monde perdu l'union
soviétique pourtant moscou conserve une
trace vivante de cette époque
ces immigrés
dans la capitale russe les anciens
peuples frères sont désormais une main
d'oeuvre bon marché
il fait moins 30 degrés oumar sort ses
premières bennes de la matinée fait
froid mais on est résistant
oumar et manutentionnaires d'un
grossiste aux liqueurs
bien voir par là le stock de votre coeur
comme la plupart des petites mains de
moscou où marc et ses collègues viennent
de la même région du monde l'asie
centrale
on vient tous les trois de la même
région au dernier qui ce temps et le
collègue là bas et les caristes
qu'ils soient tadjik kirghizes et
ouzbeks pour les russes c'est pareil à
moscou le mot tadjik est passé dans le
langage courant il désigne les ouvriers
de seconde zone venus d'asie centrale
des manoeuvres souvent chargé des
boulots les plus difficiles une
immigration qui a débuté à la chute de
l'urss
le tadjikistan une ancienne république
soviétique juché dans les montagnes
d'asie centrale un pays rural et pauvre
affaibli par six ans de guerre civile
entre 1990 et 1996 résultat des flots de
migrants ont mis le cap sur la russie
aujourd'hui le pays est le plus
dépendant au monde de l'argent envoyé
par sa diaspora
selon la banque mondiale un tiers de ces
ressources provient de ces travailleurs
migrants la majorité sont des hommes
seuls comme oumar et ses collègues
quel que soit le nombre d'années qu'on
passe ici est travaillée on garde tous
des responsabilités familiales au pays
oumar gagnent 25 mille roubles par mois
soit 650 euros c'est le prix du loyer de
son appartement
du coup omar partagent deux pièces avec
six compatriotes
il nous montre sa chambre qui est aussi
la cuisine c'est une pièce à vivre on ya
la télé notre musique un peu de notre
culture voilà ce qu'on a
at il une vie ça c'est notre chapeau
nationale
ça se porte comme ça
on ne respecte pas seulement notre
propre culture mais aussi celle de la
russie on s'adapte aux coutumes de là où
vit
ou marc a fait son service militaire
dans l'armée rouge sur le lac baïkal à
l'époque tadjik et russes étaient réunis
sous la bannière de l'union soviétique
mais aujourd'hui la grande russie lui
fait payer très cher son droit d'entrée
depuis 17 ans chaque année il doit
renouveler tous ses papiers
pour avoir ses papiers pour avoir le
droit de travailler ici ça me coûte 2000
dollars par an
ils dollars c'est près de soixante mille
roubles ça représente trois mois de
salaire
ces papiers oumar les à payer quatre
fois le prix normal au marché noir en
russie quand vous êtes tadjik ne comptez
pas sur l'administration pour tamponner
votre permis de séjour le business de
l'immigration alimentent un marché du
travail corrompus à tous les étages
un jour on mar s'est fait tabasser alors
qu'il réclamait sa paye c'est comme ça
qu'il a atterri à la fondation
tadjikistan gaffe car la présidente est
tadjik depuis 15 ans financée par un
mécène américain sa fondation lutte pour
faire respecter les droits des
travailleurs de son pays là le
tadjikistan est à 4000 km voilà moscow
ça ce sont les cas de salaires impayés
aux immigrés ça c'est le troisième tome
donc tu es
là par exemple ce sont 11 millions que
nous n'avons toujours pas récupéré
attaque catalane accio colonies plage
est la chose la plus terrible c'est la
faiblesse face aux patrons s'ils ne sont
pas payés ils ne peuvent pas se soigner
se loger ni même pire rentrer au pays
c'est dur de se battre on ne fait pas le
poids face aux patrons minustah qui suit
leur côté ses mots
du coup certains tadjik en ont assez
d'être à la merci d'un marché du travail
sans foi ni loi la solution fuir la
jungle moscovite et prendre la clé des
champs
nous sommes à 30 km de moscou sur cet
ancien kolkhoze rame où l'eau a monté sa
petite exploitation familiale grâce à
son bétail aujourd'hui il est
indépendant
je vous présente mes vaches douchka
nika
roza et martha
en ce moment pendant l'hiver elle donne
environ 140 litres de lait par jour au
printemps ce sera plus
ça me permet d'envoyer de l'argent à mon
père mon frère ma soeur tout ça nourrit
quatre familles entoure et ses vieux
pourra très
cher à moulleau on vit dans le respect
des coutumes tadjik portrait du
président au mur et danses
traditionnelles pour les plus jeunes
aujourd'hui on fête l'anniversaire et le
mariage imminent du cadet de la famille
un mariage tadjik arrangé depuis la
naissance pour payer les noces ram ou
l'eau devra vendre 4 bet la premier
arrivera du tadjikistan accompagné d'une
cinquantaine d'invités
nos enfants se sentent chez eux ici
elles font leurs études ils n'ont pas
envie de retourner là bas
avec le temps la famille sait si bien
intégré sur ses nouvelles terres que la
voisine est devenu leur babouchka leur
grand mère d'adoption
moi je suis russe en fille et je trouve
que ce sont des gens adorables
ils sont tellement bons arrêté je vais
me mettre à pleurer en russie l'image
d'une famille tadjik unis sous le même
toit est exceptionnel en ville
changement de décor chez oumar notre
manutentionnaires ici on cuisine entre
hommes
ça c'est le plf
le bluff c'est notre plat national
sans lui on n'est pas tadjik on le
prépare au moins une fois par semaine
dans le studio du marais et de ses six
amis on vit chichement maison ne se
plaint jamais le salaire tombe chaque
mois et la famille au pays reçoit les
mandats
ici tu t'ennuies jusqu'au jour où tu
trouves une maîtresse
là où on travaille à pas mal de filles
et tous les jours où mam surveille et il
me dit tu sens avec celle ci ou avec
celle là qu'est ce qu'il ya comme nana
ici
la dernière fille qui la drague et
c'était une vraie beauté elle avait 73
ans et plus dans
ces soirées entre amis sont à peu près
la seule distraction que leur offre leur
vie d'immigré encore faut-il que leurs
voisins russes les laisse tranquilles
il arrive qu'on se rassemble comme ce
soir dans un appartement et que les
voisins appellent la police
il n'aime pas les basanés ici ça ça
n'existait pas du temps de l'union
soviétique
aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas les mêmes
russes qui hier
les russes d'aujourd'hui entre sous le
règne de poutine 3
le nouveau président se fait menaçant il
promet de serrer les boulons question
immigration ce soir une marée ses amis
dormiront au chaud mais dehors des
compatriotes des neiges les rues de la
ville
c'est le paradoxe russe cette
immigration est indispensable pour la
croissance de l'économie
mais doit rester le plus invisible
possible a moscou les tadjik sont des
ombres dans la nuit
au café maya on y chantait on y danse et
on y parle aussi politique c'est nouveau
qg de la dissidence on va y rencontrer
veronica dorman c'est la correspondante
de libération à moscou avec elle on va
parler immigration vladimir poutine et à
venir de la russie
bonjour veronica on va surtout parler
immigration parce que c'est le concept
de l'émission mais on peut pas
s'empêcher de parler de politique en ce
moment en russie vladimir poutine est de
retour pour un troisième mandat au
kremlin il ya des manifs toutes les
semaines à moscou vous pensez que ça va
durer cette opposition c'est vrai que ce
mouvement-là s'essouffle un peu quoi les
gens surtout
en fait ils ont manifesté pendant trois
mois les élections ont lieu effet ce
fait si fier de nouveau et les gens
aient l'impression en fait nous servait
à rien même question qu'à l'opposition
russe et ce qui lui manque c'est un
leader en fait capable elle n'est pas
unifiée c'est un mouvement différent ça
va des nationalistes de l'extrême droite
à l'extrême gauche est en fait les
citoyens en colère donc cette masse de
gens qui sort ne se revendique d'aucun
mouvement politique en fait donc
l'opposition n'est pas unifiée alors on
ne sait pas forcément mais la russie est
un des pays qui accueillent le plus
d'immigrés dans le monde est-ce que
c'est facile immigrés en russie c'est
assez compliqué alors il ya plusieurs
choses la russie est un pays
multiethnique
historiquement il ya toujours eu un
mélange une grande variété de bétheny
qui vivraient côte-à-côte urss cpa des
républiques donc très mixte aujourd'hui
il ya un nationalisme un patriotisme
russe très fort dans une ville comme
moscou par exemple ou la migration est
essentiellement économique
c'est problématique parce qu'elle est
mal régulé parce qu' énormément migrants
clandestins parce qu'il n'ya pas de
politique pour les intégrer il n'y a pas
de désir de les intégrer et une espèce
de
d'utilisation
abusive de cette force de travail est
généralement ils ont très peu de droits
ils sont extrêmement vulnérables le
nationalisme
ambiant le ressent au quotidien à moscou
en russie il ya beaucoup de russes comme
ça dans une conversation quotidienne qui
te diront qu'ils aiment pas sympa les
étrangers ils n'aiment pas les basanés
il n'aime pas les caucasiens enfin ça
leur fait peur et en plus à cela
s'ajoute aussi un rapport très compliqué
avec le caucase parce que le cocasse et
son instabilité c'est les deux guerres
de tchétchénie
c'est les attentats perpétrés par des
des femmes kamikazes daguestanaise
voilà donc une relation très complexe et
donc le reste aussi extrêmement
concentré sur le caucase
est ce qu'il ya une stigmatisation
d'un certain type d'immigrés en russie
comme il peut
exister en france par exemple les
clichés c'est que le caucasien c'est le
poseur de bombe et le mafieux
c'est aussi
kadirov donc l'axé szczesny qui pompe à
fric monstrueux de moscou et en même
temps en étant la réponse des
républiques les plus corrompus de la
fédération de russie
et puis d'un autre côté il ya tous les
migrants d'asie centrale qui viennent à
moscou et dans les grandes villes pour
bosser sur les chantiers c'est l'état
jicks et les ouzbeks c'est les kirghizes
c'est devenu quasiment un nom commun en
fait le tadjik c'est le type qui balaie
dans ta cour qui travaillent sont ont
changé relève la neige voilà mais relève
la neige comment ça se passe quand les
immigrés arrivent en russie c'est un
parcours du combattant pour avoir des
papiers pour travailler pour s'installer
en fait ça dépend parce que des
désespoirs akkuzu organisé par exemple
on a vu les afghans qui arrivent à se
structurer entre eux et l'espèce
d'entr'aide donc l'immigré quand il
arrive il est accueilli déjà dans un
dans une structure le tadjik ouzbek ils
arrivent ils à rien il faut il et il est
tout de suite confrontées en fait à la
corruption au niveau parce que pour
avoir des papiers pour avoir
l'autorisation de travailler ici c'est
pas l'employeur qui va lui fournir ses
papiers là donc wire il emploiera si il
a déjà au préalablement une autorisation
l'autorisation et coûte de l'argent elle
est faite par des intermédiaires qui
en fait ce ping et les migrants en leur
demandant énormément de pognon pour
l'heure pour leur fournir ce papier on a
parlé des caucasiens de l'asie centrale
mais quel est le statut du noir ici ça
arrive encore dans ton des gens dire oh
il ya un singe qui passe en plus un
singe parlant ça c'est une blague
soviétique les noirs
qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient toujours le
regard ça veut dire que même quand c'est
pas malveillant
c'est un regard curieux se dire qu'on
les toisons lemmings du bois voilà en
même temps la population est beaucoup
plus soft avec eux parce qu'il pose pas
de problème en fait aux russes comme ça
de manière très générale les noirs c'est
pas une paille menace c'est pas
on a commencé par la politique on va
finir par de la politique il ya une
campagne poutine s'est décidée quand
même à faire campagne parce qu'il ya une
petite opposition donc ici et me par
rapport au discours de campagne
justement quel le russe il prépare pour
les six prochaines années la liberté
laissée fort que brice est uni et russie
qui arriverait à résister aux assauts
des diverses forces extérieures qui
veulent la nouvelle à désunir une
réussie patriotique dans son discours
tout ça c'est donc il a il a des prix là
il a publié six article fleuve son
programme politique et en lisant ça on a
l'impression qu'on est dans le plus beau
pays du monde
ça fait deux ans qu'il est au pouvoir et
s'était 12 ans qu'il n'a pas enclenché
toutes ces réformes anti parler n'a pas
commencé à construire ce pays
merveilleux merci veronica